Speaker 1: So let's talk about what's going
on with Republican Senator Mitt Romney.
You know, I think when it comes to people
like Romney, we have to be able to call things
what they are and say compared to this modern
Trumpian cult.
That includes people like Trump, Trump's family
Marjorie Taylor Greene, Lauren Boebert.
These types compared to them.
Mitt Romney seems and feels so comparatively
benign at the same time.
He's still a guy that I disagree with politically
on a number of different issues.
Mitt Romney and I have different economic
views, views on taxation, views on social
welfare programs, views on foreign policy.
And of course, of course.
But compared to the completely delusional,
weaponized nature of the modern American Trumpian
right, he's not nearly as bad.
And that doesn't mean we're glorifying Mitt
Romney.
It just says we're talking about things on
a spectrum.
He has at least taken like a minor moral stand
against the most insane aspects of the Republican
Party.
He's anti-Trump ET.
And he also mostly voted with the things that
Trump wanted, right?
Like roughly 80 percent of the time, it's
not 95 percent of the time, but it's still
80 percent of the time.
And over the weekend, Mitt Romney sort of
provided some moral clarity on CNN about Russia,
Ukraine, saying, It's very clear which side
we should be on here.
Let's take a listen to Mitt Romney
Speaker 2: would be done by the U.N. or by
us, but clearly, the humanitarian demand may
may be such that that we will look for a way
to allow the mothers and children that are
currently being huddled in subway stations
to be able to find refuge.
Right.
And look at the people of Poland, how heroic
they are provided the clothing and the housing
and the food for these refugees that are that
are pouring into their country and also in
Romania.
Look, look, this is this is one of the the
greatest demonstrations of good versus evil
that we've seen during our lifetimes and the
demonstration of courage.
I mean, look at Vladimir Putin, it's Vladimir
Putin.
Here he is in this, this behind this huge
table in this big white room.
I mean, it looks like a mausoleum where where
honesty and honor have gone to die.
And contrast that with Zelensky, with his
courage, with his passion, with his true leadership.
This is remarkable and it's having an impact.
And I hope it makes us a better people and
it makes us more committed to the principles
of freedom.
Speaker 1: So this is the perfect example
of differences of opinion with someone who,
at least on this issue, has his head modestly
on straight versus insanity like Biden, stole
the election.
Hillary should be in prison.
The vaccines are killing people, all of that
sort of stuff.
But Romney says Biden has done some really
good things putting pressure on Russia, and
he also could have done more.
That's a reasonable position.
Speaker 3: But to go back in time a little
bit.
Senator, do you think it was a mistake for
President Biden to rule out US troops on the
ground instead of trying to use what's known
as strategic ambiguity to deter Vladimir Putin
from invading in the first place?
Speaker 2: Well, there really wouldn't have
been an ambiguity.
We don't have the kind of troop strength and
materiel of war in the region to be to be
a serious threat at that point.
Look, the the Biden administration has done
some things very well and some things not
so well the not so well side as they continued
the policy of prior administrations not to
provide the defensive weapons that Ukraine
needed.
That was the mistake.
The positive thing was sharing our intelligence
with our allies and combining our efforts
with our allies.
Look, we used to be 40 percent of the world
economy today.
We're about half of that.
And so for us to have the kind of economic
clout we used to have back in the 50s and
60s and 70s, we really do need to combine
with our allies.
Speaker 1: And this is it's it's crazy that
I don't love Romney and I disagree with him
on so much stuff.
But he's at least willing to say Biden did
some things that were fine, and here's things
I would have done differently.
Whereas you have so many of these Trumpian
Republicans now who anything Biden does, anything
Biden does is by definition, bad now.
Then he got into the just absolute hammer
fists drops on on people like Marjorie Taylor
Greene and goes, Ah, he was asked about them,
and he just called them morons and said that
they're sort of like low IQ people.
Listen to this.
This is wild.
Speaker 3: You talked several times during
this interview about the world seeing the
difference between good and evil.
I want to bring that.
Closer to home and talk about something that
Congresswoman Liz Cheney tweeted yesterday.
Yes, sitting Republican House members appearing
at a white nationalist gathering.
She said quote as representative Marjorie
Taylor Greene and Paul Gosar speak at this
white supremacist anti-Semitic pro-Putin event
silenced by Republican Party leaders is deafening
and enabling all Americans should renounce
this garbage and reject the Putin wing of
the GOP.
Now, do you agree?
Speaker 2: Absolutely.
Liz Cheney was right with that statement,
and she's been right for a long time.
And I also saw that the Ronna McDaniel came
out with a statement as well talking about
how repugnant these white nationalists are.
Look, there's no place and either political
party for this white nationalism or racism,
it's simply wrong.
Speaker 1: Now, unfortunately, a place has
been made in Romney's party for it.
Like I guess he's saying, there shouldn't
be a place, but there's been a place in it
for years now.
Speaker 2: It's it's as as you've indicated.
Speaking of evil, it's evil as well.
And, you know, Marjorie Taylor Greene and
Paul Gosar, I don't know them, but I'm reminded
of that old line from the Butch Cassi